what do you say if I told you you were  gonna be my first love she totally wants  you man bothers wants my body anyway I  feel different around you than I do with  the guys  what hope so I can be myself more  what happened happened Connie and there  ain't no changing that the history is  all still there  sleep with me here what don't be stupid  just sleep next to no real man juices  some chick for his best buds I don't  know what's going on  all I want to do is just be a kid don't  forget that part of you okay  [Applause]  you'll wake up one day and you realize  that your parents are just as crazy and  messed up as we are hi Greg you uh  teaching our boy the ways of the world  can you shut up are you two gonna leave  yes we were just getting started and I'd  really like to get back to it  [Music]  you